anna kendrick i can't concentrate on
anything you're saying until you cover
your junk
space algae and deadly amounts of
radiation
netflix's stowaway or amazon prime if
you're in canada i don't know how that
works
is the latest sci-fi original showing us
just how amazing space can be
that's it man game over man it's game
over
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into it's ending some of the film's
major themes and at the end i'll explain
how one minor change could have made
this ending
far more emotional so make sure to strap
yourselves in and like and subscribe or
else my parents will throw me out of the
airlock and by
airlock i mean basement meet the crew of
mts-42
the 42nd flight from earth to mars put
together by a company called hyperion
in greek mythology hyperion was the god
of heavenly light the son of uranus and
gaia who were gods of heaven and earth
respectively
although we only see mars extremely
briefly near the end of the film
humanity has established a small outpost
with scientists and astronauts currently
conducting research there the mts-42
or mars transfer shuttle is transferring
commander marina barnett and two
scientists
david kim and zoe levinson this is
marina's third and final trip to mars
with
david and zoe along for the ride as
graduates and winners of harp
or hyperion academic research program
david's research focuses on biology
while
zoe's on medicine as she says well space
exploration has always led to amazing
medical discoveries that are
applicable to the people on earth within
the first few minutes we get the sense
something is a little off with the
mission
during takeoff the main engines seem to
be underperforming
and the ship is already off trajectory
that's because we'll later learn this
ship has an
unexpected passenger by the name of
michael adams a hyperian engineer who
passed out while making some last-minute
adjustments to the ship
and no one was like hey has anyone seen
michael but when marina finds michael
unconscious within the carbon dioxide
removal assembly a piece of equipment
that removes
co2 from the ship he inadvertently
shorts the entire system meaning that
the crew
with its now four members will die of
carbon monoxide poisoning before
reaching their destination
to make matters worse they simply can't
return back to earth
marina says they're moving too fast and
they don't have enough fuel to turn
around this is bad news for michael who
cares for his younger sister and will
miss the new season of the mandalorian
marina exhausts all options even asking
david who's a known phycologist which is
the scientific study of algae
to use his plants he was saving for mars
in an effort to get rid of the co2
all his years of work building up to
this research will be gone
but it's a sacrifice he's willing to
make to ensure they all survive
and sacrifice is one of the film's
biggest themes as we'll get to in a bit
unfortunately the second batch of algae
which david puts together
fails and the crew is once again faced
with the dilemma that they only have
enough
air to get three of them to mars alive
if those three are to live
one of the four has to die of course
they decide not to tell michael about
this with commander marina giving them
and the ground crew back home
10 days to figure out an alternative
solution before something drastic must
be done
but david believing there is no
alternative tells michael the situation
and gives him a needle to basically kill
himself but things get even worse for
the crew when the first batch of algae
dies meaning all of them will die
unless they find a way to get
supplemental oxygen luckily for them the
kingfisher the rocket they're tethered
to which is basically slingshotting them
to mars
may have some leftover oxygen in it but
they'll have to make the arduous journey
along the tether and down the side of
the rocket as they fly through space to
get to it both david and zoe agree to
make the trek seeing as michael has no
training
and marina's arm broke when michael fell
on her at the beginning the ship's use
of central pedal force in which the two
ends of the craft the kingfisher here
and the hyperion here
rotate around the center solar arrays
they create a type of artificial gravity
for the astronauts where the
force is greater near the ends i hope i
got that right or else i'm going to have
a lot of angry astrophysicists in my
comments
no no it's 3.14 oh you idiot you didn't
know that
tapping into the rocket's oxygen supply
is short-lived when the crew is alerted
to an
incoming solar storm leaving them 20
minutes to get back safely
and not enough time to finish filling
the two tanks they need to survive
and on her way back zoe loses the only
canister of
oxygen they were able to retrieve you
idiot leaving the
entire crew with no hope for survival or
so we think
about three quarters of the way through
the movie zoe tells a story about how
she almost drowned saving a man when she
was a lifeguard
but she was miraculously saved when a
nearby boater pulled her out of the
water it's a story she tells to michael
about
never giving up hope it's ironic then
that zoe becomes that hope for the crew
when she sacrifices herself to retrieve
the last
oxygen canister still attached to the
rocket but since it's leaking precious
oxygen she must brave the radioactive
solar storm
killing herself in the process we
already mentioned why michael and marina
couldn't do this and david offers to go
but zoe says he has a wife back home and
that he should go back to her and make
babies and send their kid off to yale
her
alma mater thus she ends up braving the
radioactive storm to save the entire
crew
the ending shot here mimics the first
shot of the film only this time the
camera is moving away from zoe instead
of on to her
and here zoe dies staring at the faint
red dot that is mars in the distance she
never got to reach mars that thing she's
been striving for her
entire life but in sacrificing her life
she allows others to live out theirs
it's a tragic ending which for me lacked
the emotional weight i think it was
trying to pull
and this leads into my main critique of
the film while others may think this
movie lacks action found in other films
of the genre like gravity or life it's
not trying to be that movie and as such
it relies on
character however our main character
doesn't have a character arc
the zoe we meet at the beginning of the
film is the same zoe we see at the end
she hasn't learned anything or changed
as a result of the journey she's been
put on
if i were writing this movie and wanted
zoey to sacrifice herself at the end it
would be far more emotional if the zoe
we see at the beginning of the film
was written to be the least likely
person to sacrifice themselves
maybe they're a coward or stubborn or
put their work before
everything else something so that when
her sacrificial decision is made
we see the weight of it and that change
in her character great character arcs
always have this huge shift like luke
skywalker starting off as a cowardly
farm boy on tatooine to masterful
fighter pilot or walter white the
innocent high school chemistry teacher
to drug
kingpin you're goddamn right i have a
whole video on star wars and character
arcs which you should totally check out
if you have the time but what did you
think of stowaway i want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at
yt until next time remember daddy loves
you very much